لقي مقطع فيديو على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي التفاعلا واسعا لفلاح عراقي وهو
يرقص تحت اله الحصاد بطريقه عفويه فرحا
بمحصوله من القمح هذا الموسم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انتشر المقطع فيديو يظهر الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان وهو يرفض شرب كوب من
الماء من يد حارسه الشخصي ثم عاد وتناوله
من يد ابنه بلاد
[موسيقى]
تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو للمحتجه على السجاد الحمراء في
مهرجان كان سينمائي مرتديه فستانا بالوان
العلم الاوكراني وتسكب على نفسها دماءا
مزيفه قبل ان يتدخل الامن ويخرجها من
المكان
[موسيقى]
يظن البعض انه طفل بعمر العشر سنوات شاب
يمني يعجز عن اقناع الناس بانه طبيب وعمره
30 عاما في واحده من اغرب الحالات الطبيه
يتميز الصيدلانيه اليمني هايل للسودي بجسد
طفل رغم تجاوزه سنه 30 عاما وذكر السود
لوسائل اعلام انه تعرض لحاده سقوط من
الدور الثاني ما ادى الى توقف نموه لكنه
اكمل حياته الدراسيه بشكل طبيعي وحصل على
دبلوم وبكالوريوس صيدله
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات